the sons of Sir Edmund Hillary and
Tenzing nogue Place traditional Tibetan
scarfs on statues of their fathers
it's part of a ceremony in lukna in
Nepal to Mark 70 years since the pair
climbed to the summit of Mount Everest
[Music]
they changed history and in the years
that followed many lives
I'm in this position today because I
studied in a school established with the
support of Tenzing Norgay and Sir Edmund
Hillary I respect them a lot and would
encourage people around the world to
come and visit Mount Everest
New Zealander Hillary and Napoleon negei
reached the world's highest peak in May
1953. two unassuming men had climbed the
29 000 foot Monarch of the Himalayas
thousands of climates have since
followed them but hundreds have also
died during their attempts and now
climate change is making the Trek even
more dangerous I've been in mountains
for 50 years and to see the the mass of
uh loss of ice is just as mind-blowing
and what it means is that the Glaciers
are far more broken far more challenging
sometimes in the most difficult part of
a climb is actually just accessing the
climb and that's all down to to our
climate warming
the Hindu Kush and Himalayan mountain
regions are home to nearly 2 billion
people a quarter of the world's
population they depend on water that
flows from the glaciers scientists
predict that in the next 70 years
two-thirds of the ice will disappear the
70th anniversary is occasion for us both
to look back on the historic achievement
but also to look forward as soon with
Hillary always did to how to secure a
sustainable future for the people of the
solo cumber Hillary under gay success
has helped create an industry that
employs thousands of people in Nepal but
70 years on climate change is putting
that at risk Sara Gill Al Jazeera